i think a lot of folks who are listening
to this hear about regulation they feel
that there is uh some tension between
the companies in the space and
regulators both in the united states and
also internationally as well i want to
use kind of the
tangible example of the lend product
that you all um had you know kind of
ideated on you wanted to create and
launch uh there is this now infamous
twitter thread that you put together and
put out publicly kind of calling
attention to the fact that you didn't
think you were gonna be able to launch
it and maybe just walk us through kind
of how uh this process works and you
know both i think from uh if you can
what you think coinbase is kind of doing
to to move towards a uh a solution but
also maybe from the regulator's
standpoint are there things that you
think like yes they're doing this and
that's actually a good thing uh it's a
fair thing to be doing and if there's
anything that they're doing that uh that
you think could be improved or changed
yeah sure so the lend product was kind
of um an interesting example for us by
the way the the lend product is not
really material to our revenue at this
point or anything like that but it's um
it's an interesting case
because
some of our you know competitors great
companies and crypto by the way um
have had a product like that out in the
market for a couple of years we've we've
seen demand from our own customers to
have it and so we decided that we wanted
to go out and put out a similar product
um what was frustrating is that we
proactively went to the to the sec ahead
of time we've been telling them about
our development of this product
and um we felt like we had buy in there
but as it approached our launch date we
suddenly saw a much different stance
from them
and they came out and said we well you
can't not only do we have concerns do
not launch this and if you do we'll
we'll be suing you and they sent us a
wells notice which is kind of like a
preliminary document before you sue
somebody
so the product never launched
but i was kind of frustrated by that
because i felt like
well
the goal of the sec is to protect
consumers and then create a level
playing field
so
you know number one um how are they
protecting consumers in this case i
think a lot of consumers demonstrably
have wanted to earn higher yields on
their
on their savings accounts and things
like that they're not really getting
those products from the existing
financial services so that was one open
question and then the second one was how
are they creating level playing field
because it seems like other companies
are have been able to do this but
coinbase suddenly is not allowed to
sometimes we're we're a more well-known
company
we're a bigger company and so we sort of
get this scrutiny that other startups
don't have by the way i kind of
understand that the sec is just one
organization they don't have time to
look at every startup but they kind of
can look at the big ones
um
so we were stuck in this kind of
uncomfortable position where the sec
would not tell us why they didn't why
they thought it wasn't shouldn't be
allowed
they were very close-lipped about that
i'm not sure why maybe they didn't want
to
tip their hand in some kind of
litigation or something but it just
didn't feel collaborative or uh being
upfront at all
um and they and they were creating the
sun level playing field in the process
so at the end of the day we sort of
talked to our lawyers about it and they
felt like what's what is our case here
like should we go you know we're being
harmed should we should we proactively
sue the sec should we uh just enter
litigation with them and try to create
some kind of legal precedent
but we felt like there's a lot of
deference given to um regulators in the
court system and we we have frankly no
desire to be engaged in drawn out
litigation with any regulator right i
consider that to be very much a last
resort
we always want to be proactive and
collaborative with people
and so we decided not to launch the
product essentially we're going to wait
and see what the sec does in terms of
the other products that are out there
already in the market um where it's it's
not a level playing field today um i
think we want to also just focus our
efforts on maybe even more important
things happening in crypto like
the questions around which of these
tokens are securities and how is defy
going to be used um
there's you know these are the things
that i guess we really want to stand
behind and sort of say these are the
benefits to the crypto community that we
want to go
make sure there's a good legal precedent
for um but i you know i when i went to
dc i reached out to the sec i tried to
get a meeting with them
um they told me that they weren't
meeting with any crypto companies i was
kind of surprised by that um because
there are so many different regulators
out there every single one has been
willing to meet with us and every other
branch of government by the way and scc
was really the only regulator that i was
not able to get a meeting with as a new
the first crypto public company in the
united states that they weren't willing
to meet with me when i went to dc so
there's something kind of strange going
on there i wish that we would basically
all just be able to pick up the phone
and talk about this stuff it doesn't
need to be in a
combative stance and whenever i see
something like that happening that i
think is kind of
inauthentic and you know i i i tend to
talk about it publicly i want to put
this stuff out in the in the ether so
that the world can know about it and
they can make up their own mind about um
how these things should play out in
government so i want to ask uh kind of a
couple of different perspectives from
this specific situation because i think
it's a good tangible example uh where
people can understand uh both your
perspective and also the regulators uh
as a publicly traded ceo uh especially
one that it just came into public
markets if you went and you talked to
somebody in the legacy finance world
they would say oh my god that is nuts to
do a public thread and talk about the
sec et cetera how do you think about uh
risk reward in terms of having the
conversation and kind of pushing forward
to what i think
you know based from what i understand
you've said publicly and also uh
elsewhere is um you know really trying
to work towards the solution like how do
you view that uh moving towards the
solution and did you evaluate any sort
of risk with kind of being more public
maybe so than than other people would
yeah so i mean
look there's no right answer here okay
so i'm not going to come out and say
that it's the right thing to do or it's
the wrong thing to do a lot of this
stuff comes down to kind of gut at the
end of the day and um the way i thought
about it was
um you know
first of all twitter twitter is a funny
thing because if i had gone on to um
cnbc or something like that and said the
same thing people would have probably
thought like oh that was a healthy
debate or dialogue there's something
about twitter which um you know
people it's a very much like a west
coast and east coast thing right so on
the east coast the the reaction to my
tweet i'd say was more negative people
were like wow how could he do that um
you know he should be going through
appropriate channels and you know wall
street journal or or whatever
and people on the west coast were like
that was the best thing i've seen you
know all year and they were like finally
somebody's willing to just speak the
truth about what's going on behind the
scenes and put it out there in the open
right
um and so i think there's just a
cultural difference that's happening
look my my i'm not naturally a combative
person i'm actually like kind of
conflict avoidant right like i my
default is to go build genuine
relationships with people just try to
work on stuff like even if we disagree
there's there's a way to make it win win
and just move forward but if somebody is
you know if they're not going to meet
with us
to even have a conversation which by the
way i still my my optimistic view is
that we can change that um we still
haven't gotten a meeting with the sec
for someone you know high up there or
gender to talk to me personally but my
hope is that that's still on the table
um and if i can't get that then
eventually i'm just going to go out and
talk about it publicly so that people
can know about it i think it's a form of
accountability frankly um and that's
like the way that the this is trending
in the future it's it's going to be
companies are less going to be going
through traditional channels cnbc
um
you know wall street journal mainstream
media new york times they're going to be
bypassing that and going direct to their
community via modern tools you know
blogs podcasts like this one
twitter and you know youtube and all the
modern tools that are out there so it's
just it's an interesting cultural moment
where
west coast companies i think are
starting to take a different view on
this than the east coast
and when you look at it from the
regulator perspective
it almost feels like one like you said
there's so much stuff going on uh i
definitely do not envy being a regulator
right now in terms of trying to figure
out uh not only you know what is uh
inbounds or out of bounds but also just
like what to go focus on first i went
through the exercise recently and said
to myself you know if you're a regulator
and you stack rank all the different
things going on in this industry like
what do you even go look at first it's
hard to just do that exercise alone and
so
are there areas where you think that uh
and crypto companies a lot of folks who
run other companies or investors in the
industry
can kind of meet in the middle like like
what is that middle ground where you
think you're like okay this is the
activities that we should go focus on
that can actually push this forward get
to solutions on some of these issues
and ultimately i think find some balance
between the uh kind of economic
empowerment the innovation the job
creation all the things that we know to
be positive but also satisfy whatever
the the concerns are of whether it's
regulators politicians etc
yeah so i totally agree by the way i
have a lot of empathy for regulators in
this space because they have a very hard
job it's so new it's changing so quickly
um you know frankly i would have a very
hard time getting out there and sort of
publishing clear guidance on it i think
it's i think it's very difficult but
coinbase has been thinking about you
know what we can do to help here in fact
when i was in dc one of the most common
things people asked me was can you help
draft something you and your lawyers
helped draft something that would be
proposal a proposal about how this
industry could be regulated more
efficiently right so that coinbase
doesn't have to have
50 plus regulators in just one country
um and then and we don't have this kind
of jump ball between the different
federal agencies
so
actually we've been working on a draft
proposal uh a regulatory framework for
the industry we're gonna be publishing
that probably in the next two weeks or
so and
it's meant to say not that we have all
the answers but it's it's a start to the
conversation
and i think it could make sense to have
um
one agency or basically uh you know a
division within one of the existing
agencies
be the
the single point of regulation a single
federal regulator in the united states
um that can help this this industry get
a little bit of clarity so that this
industry can be built in the united
states effectively and the us can kind
of maintain its position um as a
financial hub and a leader in technology
with with appropriate regulation in
place so i think we basically all want
to think the same thing we want to help
the industry grow but have some
reasonable regulation that's thoughtful
and i guess we want to try to be part of
the solution here not not just engaging
in you know um antagonism and so we're
going to put out a proposal there and i
hope people are willing to come talk to
us about it what's up guys bang bang
thanks so much for watching the best
business show today if we're going to be
the best business show we obviously need
the best partner that's why the
exclusive sponsor the best business show
is sofi they're an all-in-one platform
that allows you to invest in all kinds
of different assets including stocks
etfs crypto ipos and they even have an
automated investing function if that's
your thing so before we start getting
after it again make sure that you go
download sofi you get an invest account
and when you make your first crypto
trade regardless of what you buy they'll
give you ten dollars in bitcoin for free
it's that simple head on over to
sofi.com to get started today thanks so
much for watching and i hope you come
back and watch more the best business
show tomorrow
[Music]